salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
dans quelques jours sort sur les écrans
de cinéma le film Oppenheimer on en
parle depuis pas mal de temps c'est
normal c'est le dernier film de
Christopher Nolan le réalisateur
d'interstellar Dunkerque ou ténètnet
récemment openheimer est un biopic sur
Julius Robert hoenheimer le savant qui a
mis au point la bombe atomique alors on
ne va pas refaire le film dans cette
vidéo on va plutôt s'arrêter sur son
invention comment une telle bombe peut
faire autant de victimes et de dégâts et
pour bien mesurer le danger on verra ce
qui se passerait si une bombe comme
celle-ci tombait sur Paris
on est en plein été mais ça fait froid
dans le dos
[Musique]
le 6 août 1944 les États-Unis font usage
pour la toute première fois dans
l'histoire de l'arme atomique leur cible
une ville japonaise Hiroshima la
puissance de cette bombe surnommée
little boy est estimé à 12 kg
l'équivalent de 15000 tonnes de TNT ou
22000 tonnes de dynamique une des
Américains contraindre le Japon allié de
l'Allemagne nazie à capituler sans
condition et mettre un terme au combat
afin d'épargner des vies humaines mais à
l'arrivée le bilan était froyable
environ 140
000 morts quant au survivant il souffre
de brûlures de lésions internes sans
compter les dégâts invisibles au départ
mais qui vont entraîner d'importantes
pertes humaines à cause des radiations
liées à l'usage de la matière ficile
trois jours plus tard le 9 août 1945 un
bombardier large une deuxième bombe
encore plus puissante sur une autre
ville japonaise
elle fait 80 000 morts pour les
Américains l'objectif est atteint ces
deux événements tragiques mettent fin à
la guerre du Pacifique le 2 septembre
1945 le Japon capitule celui qui a mis
au point cette arme cataclysmique
s'appelle Julius Robert openheimer nous
sommes en 1942 dans le plus grand secret
le gouvernement américain lance un
programme de recherche sur un nouveau
type de bombe la bombe nucléaire nom de
code projet Manhattan avec à sa tête le
physicien américain Julius Robert
openheimer l'idée à émergé trois ans
plus tôt en août 1939 lorsqu’un
collectif de physiciens dont fait partie
Albert Einstein adresse une lettre
président américain Franklin de la
norosvelt ils veulent l'avertir qu'il
est techniquement possible de réaliser
une bombe ultra puissante en utilisant
de grandes quantités d'uranium fervent
pacifiste Einstein est convaincu que les
scientifiques au service des nazis vont
se servir de cette découverte pour créer
une bombe atomique ce serait un désastre
le prix Nobel de physique suggère donc
aux États-Unis d'acquérir des stocks
d'uranium dans le but d'accélérer la
recherche sur la réaction en chaîne
Roosevelt prend cette alerte très au
sérieux il nomme alors openheimer
coordinateur du projet c'est l'un des
plus grands scientifiques de son époque
il s'est fait remarquer notamment en
démontrant que l'univers contenait des
trous noirs je ne mettant pas sur ce
sujet on fera ça dans une prochaine
vidéo s'il suffisait vous intéresse
dites le moi en commentaire durant trois
ans Oppenheimer et ses équipes
travaillent sur la fission de l’uranium
et du plutonium depuis leur laboratoire
situé à Los Alamos au Nouveau-Mexique et
le 16 juillet 1945 la toute première
bombe nucléaire explose dans le désert
d'Alamo Gordo en créant un nuage de 13
km de hauteur Robert hopenheimer A si sa
mission la bombe atomique est prête
Albert Einstein lui n'a pas été
sollicité pour faire partie du projet
Manhattan il n'avait d'ailleurs même pas
été mis au courant il découvre
l'existence de la bombe atomique en même
temps que le reste du monde le 6 août
1945 le jour où elle explose sur
Hiroshima il est horrifié peu avant sa
mort en 1955 il écrit un manifeste pour
la paix réclamant la disparition des
armes atomiques de la surface de la
Terre considérant que ces travaux ont
permis de concevoir de tels armes il
déclare même à la fin de sa vie que si
sa carrière était à refaire il aurait
préféré devenir plombier ou colporteur
quant à Robert hoffenheimer il exprimera
aussi des regrets estimant kiroshima et
Nagasaki ont été bien plus coûteux en
vie et en souffrance que ce que voulait
les concepteurs de la bombe pour arrêter
la guerre
de bombes on suffit pour faire quasi
instantanément 220 000 morts érayé deux
villes japonaises de la carte comment
des engins peuvent-ils faire autant de
dégâts et de victimes qu'est-ce
qu'oenheimer et ses équipes ont mis au
point la bombe atomique ou bon a est
aussi appelé bombe à fission nucléaire
fission nucléaire c'est le nom de la
réaction qui produit cette énergie
dévastatrice elle repose sur
l'utilisation non pas d'explosifs comme
dans une bombe classique mais de
matériaux instables de l'uranium pour la
bombe qui a explosé sur Hiroshima du
plutonium pour celle qui a explosé sur
Nagasaki dans les deux cas le principe
est le même ces deux métaux sont
constitués d'atomes des grains de
matières invisibles à l’œil nu qui se
casse facilement on dit qu'ils sont
instables c'est ça la fission ces atomes
sont constitués d'un noyau composé
lui-même de protons en rouge et de
neutrons en verre quand un atome
d'uranium ou de plutonium se brise en
deux il libère de l'énergie et aussi
deux ou trois neutrons qui à leur tour
peuvent provoquer la fission d'autres
noyaux d'uranium ou de plutonium pour
provoquer une explosion comme un agazaki
ou comme celle qui génère ce genre de
champignons atomique il faut beaucoup
d'atomes
et si ça tombait sur Paris et bien je ne
donne pas cher de ta peau ce scénario
très peu probable à toutefois été
imaginé par des scientifiques tout
d'abord en moins d'un millionième de
seconde une boule de feu d'un rayon de
260 mètres se formerait au-dessus de la
ville qui très rapidement prendrait la
forme d'un champignon le fameux
champignon atomique à sa base la chaleur
atteindrait 7000 degrés dans un rayon
d'un kilomètre tout ce qui vit toutes
les infrastructures les immeubles les
véhicules le mobilier urbain tout serait
pulvérisé mais l'explosion serait si
puissante quel engendrerait des pertes
humaines et des dégâts matériels sur une
surface de 32 km². la moitié des
arrondissements de Paris serait touché
ça va on habite un peu plus loin et bien
pas vraiment
le rayon d'action d'une bombe atomique
s'étend au-delà du rayonnement thermique
et de l'onde de choc provoquée par
l'explosion la désintégration de la
matière ficile contenue dans la bombe
génère des radiations qui se propagent
beaucoup plus loin elle provoque des
dommages corporels irrémédiatsiables les
rayons pénètrent dans les tissus et
détériore l'ADN des cellules les
victimes qui au départ ne se rendent
compte de rien développe dans les
semaines qui suivent des cancers des
personnes qui ont échappé à l'explosion
seraient également exposés au
rayonnement résiduel émis par des
poussières ou de la vapeur d'eau rendu
radioactive après l'explosion ces
éléments radioactifs peuvent s'élever à
10 000 mètres de hauteur voire plus sous
la forme d'un nuage qui peut atteindre
400 km de long ensuite elles finissent
par retomber au sol tous les organismes
vivants animaux ou végétaux qui entrent
en contact avec ses poussières les
ingères
ou les inhal seraient contaminées une
fois dans l'organisme les particules
vont se fixer sur certains tissus ou
organes comme le foie les muscles et le
squelette ayoshima et à Nagasaki les
bonbons ont en fait causer la mort
d'environ 340 000 personnes à Paris on
estime qu'une telle bombe ferait 600 000
morts et plus d'un million de blessés je
vous l'avais dit ça fait froid dans le
dos et pourtant ce n'est rien à côté de
la bombe H la bombe thermonucléaire on
dit aussi bon mal hydrogène a été mise
au point quelques années après la bombe
A elle est encore plus redoutable elle
dégage encore plus d'énergie la plus
puissante des bombes H a été testé par
l'ex Union Soviétique en 1961 par contre
des populations dans un archipel
inhabité de l'océan Arctique situé sur
son territoire elle avait été baptisée
zarbomba cette arme était 4000 fois plus
puissante que l'été la qui a rasé
Hiroshima 50000 kg contre 12 kg pour
vous faire une idée jetez un oeil sur
les champignons générés par ces deux
bombes à gauche little boy lancé sur
Hiroshima à droite sarbonate pour info
les bombes qui équipent les SNL français
les sous-marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins font 100 kg tonnes lors du test
la Tsar Bomba a provoqué un séisme de 5
sur l'ancienne échelle de Richter on l'a
dit la bombe atomique et l'arme la plus
destructrice que l’homme et jamais
inventé mais paradoxalement c'est aussi
celle qui a permis d'éviter une guerre
mondiale depuis plus de 60 ans en effet
peu après la fin de la seconde guerre en
1945 le monde se retrouve divisé en deux
blocs à l'est les forces du pacte de
Varsovie dominé par l'Union soviétique à
l'ouest les forces de l'OTAN emmenées
par les États-Unis entre les deux c'est
la guerre froide chacun braque ses
missiles nucléaires sur le camp d'en
face mais sans la même être la menace à
exécution celui qui osera larguer ça bon
moment premier le sait il échappera pas
en retour au fenugre c'est ce qu'on
appelle la dissuasion nucléaire elle est
fondée sur une crainte réciproque des
conséquences liées à l'emploi de
l'armatomie on parle aussi d'équilibre
par la terreur aujourd'hui en vertu d'un
traité signé par 180 pays seuls la
Russie la Chine la France le Royaume-Uni
et les États-Unis sont autorisés à
posséder la bombe atomique enfin ça
c'est en théorie certains pays ont passé
outre le traité l'Inde le Pakistan
Israël la Corée du Nord et l'Afrique du
Sud qui depuis son nez débarrasser de
son côté la France possède environ
250 têtes nucléaires et quatre
sous-marins ce arsenal est stocké à 90%
à l'île longues en face de Brest chaque
souverain peut embarquer 16 missiles et
chaque missile porte six bombes
nucléaires chaque bombe affiche une
puissance de 100 kg de quoi détruire une
grande ville en France seul le président
de la République a le pouvoir de
déclencher le feu nucléaire souhaitons
que la dissuasion reste la règle en tout
cas le désarmement n'est pas pour demain
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui j'espère que
cette vidéo vous a plu c'est l'été
profitez-en chers épicurieuses et
épicurieux bonne semaine et à dimanche
prochain
[Musique]